في رساله مؤثره ودع الرئيس البرازيليه
المتخبه لويس اناسيو لولا دا سيلفا اسطوره
بلاده قائلا على تويتر ودعنا بليلجد مكانا
له في الجنه الى جانب صديقه وزميله في
نادي سانتوس كوتينيو لقد ترك لنا حقيقه هي
انه لم يكن هناك رقم 10 مثله اما الرئيس
البرازيلي المنتهيه شهيره بوسنارو انا نجم
الاجيال لحمل اسم البرازيلي في العالم
وحول كره القدم الى فن وفرح من جديد اكد
الرئيس الاسبق للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بارك اوباما انبيليه كان من اعظم اللاعبين
في رياضه كره القدم معتبرا انه احد اشهر
الرياضي العالم لفهمه قوه الرياضه في
التقريبي ما بين الشعوب
[تصفيق]
رياضيا حرس نجوم ومسؤولون وانديه كره
القدم على رثاء النجم البرازيليه السابق
بلي
س الذين يحبون كره القدم هذا بالتاكيد هو
اليوم الذي لم يكن نرغب فيه ابدا
فقدنا الملك ونشعر الان بالفرح نشعر
بالحزن
انه الى الابد مع كل شخص يحب كره القدم
بسبب ما فعله من اجل كره القدم
رونالدو
دول الفرنسي كيليان بقيه كتب ايضا رحل ملك
كره القدم عنا لكن ارثه هو لن ينسى ابدا
اما المهاجم البرازيلي نيمار دا سيلفا فقد
كتب في تغريده له انها بنيجي على كره
القدم فنا
كره طويله للاعب استثنائي
نجوم هوليود ورؤساء دول وغير من شكل كره
القدم داخل وخارج المستطيل الاخضر اجماعا
من قبل محبيه وخصومه الرياضيين على السواء
رحلت اليه لكن في قلوب محبيه لا يزالوا
اعظم من الحياه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
دعوه فروزن
[تصفيق]